hi there what you're seeing here is an
energy based model that learns the
concept of a shape from a demonstration
on the left so on the left you can see a
demonstration of data point sampled from
a shape in these cases circles or
squares and then the corresponding
energy function that the model in first
from that and then it can replicate that
shape on the right using that energy
function so the paper we're going to
analyze today is called concept learning
with energy based models by yegor more
Dutch of open AI and this is a very cool
paper or at least I think it's a very
cool paper but it is also a very hard
paper so therefore first I want to kind
of make a bit of an introduction into
the concepts that we are facing in this
paper so the first thing you need to
know are energy functions or energy
based models what is an energy function
an energy function sometimes called e is
simply a function with one or multiple
inputs let's call them X and you can
make the if the energy function is happy
with X it will be the value 0 and if the
energy function is not happy with X it
will be a high value like larger than
zero so this is happy this is not happy
so let's give some examples of this we
can formulate almost any machine
learning problem in terms of an energy
function let's say we have a classifier
the classifier is takes as an input
image here may be of a cat and the label
so if the label is cat then the energy
will be zero if the energy function is
of course working correctly and if but
if we give the energy function the same
image but we give it a wrong label dog
then it is very high in the case of the
classifier of course we can
to simply take the loss function as the
energy function and we are altom
automatically get an energy based model
so the loss function here would be
something like the negative log
probability of the of the sorry of the
correct class but in any case it is just
going to be a high number let's call it
10 to the 9 so the energy function says
ha this is very this is very bad this
thing here is very bad the entire thing
you input it won't tell you yet what's
bad about it so that also means you can
change any of the two things to make the
classifier happy now usually we're
concerned with changing the label it's
like tell me which other label do I need
to input to make you happy and if we
make the labels differentiable of course
we never input the true label we
actually input like a distribution
softmax distribution over labels and
that's a differentiable we can use
gradient descent to update the dog label
we can use gradient descent to find the
label that would make the energy
function more happy so we could use
gradient descent to get the cat level if
we had a good classifier but we can also
we can also optimize the image to make
it compatible with the dog label right
that's things that if you ever saw deep
dream or something like this those
models do exactly that they optimize the
input image for a particular label and
there you can view the entire neural
network including the loss function as
the energy function so what's another
example another example is let's say you
have a k-means model and the energy
function is simply input a data point
and for the data point what you're going
to do is you're going to find the min
cluster index the min Kay over you know
you have your multiple clusters here and
your data point might be here so you're
going to fight the cluster that's
closest and then the distance here this
since Dee will be the energy of that so
the model is very happy when your data
point it comes from one of the clusters
but your model is not happy when the
data point is far away and that would be
the cost function of the k-means
function so that's an energy based model
too now currently energy based models
have come into fashion through things
like Gans or any conservative noise
contrastive estimation so in a jet in a
gam what you have is you have a
discriminator and the discriminator will
basically learn a function to
differentiate data from non data so that
by itself is an energy function so the
discriminator will learn a function and
that function will be low wherever the
discriminator thinks there is a data
right so it will usually do this around
the data point so the data points form
the valleys right here and then the
generator will basically take that
discriminator function and will try to
infer points that are also in these
valleys to produce points that are also
in the valleys and then you basically
have an energy learning competition the
discriminator now tries to push down on
the energy where the true data is and
push up on the energy where the
generated data is and that will give you
basically a steeper energy based
function in the future I hope so in this
case the discriminator neural network is
the energy function and the D generator
just tries to produce data that is
compatible with that energy function so
I hope that concept of what an energy
function is is a bit clearer and in any
again any machine learning problem can
be formulated in terms of an energy
function now what is not done so far is
what we alluded to a little bit before
in the classifier example and also here
so right now when we want to Train again
we simply take the generator to
whose data now what's the generator
skull the generators goal is to hit
those valleys in the energy function and
we produce a generator into in one shot
produce this data but what we could also
do is of course we could just start
somewhere let's say here we pick a
random data point and then we use
gradient descent because the energy
function in this case is smooth we use
gradient descent to just drop down this
valley and then find ourselves in this
valley
so without ever training a generator we
can use this methods to produce points
that are in the valley of the energy
function right and this I don't know if
people I can guess people have trained
gams like this the reason why it doesn't
work let's say in the real world is
because that procedure will just produce
adversarial examples for the
discriminator and those usually look
like nothing like data because if you
keep the discriminator just stable and
gradient descent against it what you'll
get isn't really qualitatively good but
in principle if the discriminator was a
good energy function for the date to
describe the data we could use gradient
descent the same up here in order to
find a good label for an image given
that we have a good energy function
right so this is that we could simply
gradient descent on the label in order
to find a better in order to find a
better label so in this paper we're
going to have a situation where we say
we're given an energy function and we're
given a bunch of inputs they are then
called X a and W and if I have my energy
function already if I have given my
energy function and I have given two of
those three things any two right I can
infer the last thing simply by gradient
descent on my energy function because I
know the energy function is zero
when all of these when the energy
function is happy with the input so when
all of these things agree basically the
energy function is happy it will output
zero otherwise it will output a high
value therefore if I given any of those
two any two of those three things I can
find a compatible third thing by
descending and then of course over here
in these machine learning problems the
task was always actually to learn an
energy function right so usually in the
training dates that we are given images
and labels and we want to learn this
energy function which would be
parameterized so we want to learn the
parameters and the same here in our
general case if we are now given three
things but we are not given the
parameters of the energy function we
don't know what those are
as long as we're given all of the inputs
and our training data set and our
training data set guarantees these are
actually you know these are inputs that
are compatible with each other the
energy function should below we can
simply gradient descent on the
parameters of the energy function so in
a sense there are four things right
there are these three inputs and then
there are the parameters of the energy
function if we're given any three of
those four we can gradient descent on
the rest and that's going to be the
basis so the X here is going to be the
so-called state and the state in this
paper is going to be images of entities
the entities sorry is not going to be
images but the entities are these little
circles that you're going to see and
each of those entities can have an
exposition a Y position and I believe a
color so our G and B so each of those
can have that and then the concatenation
of all of those attributes is a one big
vector and that is your X that's your
state so state is number of entities and
their attributes a is going to be an
attention mask over the state so a is
going to be
here you have four entities so a will
have four entries telling you which of
these entities you should pay attention
to right now and W is going to be a
concept vector so called so W is going
to be the embedding of a concept now
what a concept is in this case is very
general I can give you an example one a
concept is do any of do the entities
that the a pays attention to are they
close to each other so in this case you
see we have two entities that a has a
high value one and this is this all up
here and this ball down here now if the
concept vector is the embedding for the
concept of being close to each other
then the energy function would be very
happy if those two things are close to
each other and it would be very unhappy
if those two things aren't close to each
other but in the very same situations of
the same X the same attention mask but a
different concept so a different W
vector right here then the the energy
function would be maybe very happy if
the two things are far apart and maybe
unhappy if the two things are close so
the question is always how are the three
things that you put into the energy
function compatible with each other and
given all but one of these things you
can infer the other so let's say you
have a perfect energy function for this
this all of these for this situation
you're just given the energy function
you can trust it and you are given let's
make an example you are given the X so
you're given the state I'm gonna draw
the state down here right okay
this is the state and you were given the
W and the W is the embedding it's a
vector but the embedding space but the
embedding is for a line right so the
geometric the geometric unit of a line
now your task is to find a the attention
mask that will make the energy function
happy and as you can see right here
while you would do is you would put a
lot of weight on this this this and this
ball and no weight on that ball because
those make a line and since everything
here is differentiable so the state is
differentiable the attentions
differentiable and the concepts or
vectors that are differentiable you can
use gradient descent to find that
another example if you're given again
the same W so line and you were given
this following thing and you were given
now you're given the attention on these
three and you say please find the X
please find the X the states that makes
this energy function happy now this here
you would call the starting state the x0
your ear task is going to be find the x1
find the state how do you have to change
this state such that the energy function
is happy and of course the answer is
going to be is to push this ball here
inward until it is in the middle of the
two others so the three form a line
right these three form a line you don't
you don't have to do anything to this
ball up here because there is no
attention on it and the attention it's
only is the concept for the things that
you put attention on yeah and the state
are those three in agreement and the
energy function is happy okay we have
covered the basics now let's dive into
the paper I think this is the longest
introduction ever but I think it will
pay off once
see so they they specifically or this
this author I think it's a single author
identifies two different things that you
can do with an energy function here of
course you can do more as we saw but
they identify two so here is where you
have given the initial state and an
attention mask and you want to find the
x1 the state that satisfies the concept
and the tension the most this the author
calls generation as you can see here
these four things that you have the
attention on are pushed around until
they make a square because the concept
right now is square and in the other
case where you are given this x0 and x1
just call this X right here just call
this thing X if you're given those two
and you are given the concept Square and
you're tasked with finding a the
attention mask of course you're going to
put the attention on these right here
and that is going to happen through
gradient descent again we're not
learning a model to give you that
attention like in again we're learning a
generator to just one shot give it to
you right now what we're going to do is
we're going to gradient descent optimize
on our smooth energy function to give us
that perfect attention mask that
satisfies the energy function all right
so this is the difference right here
gradient descent is part of the output
procedure of the model usually we just
use it to learn and we learn a one-shot
model but here gradient descent is part
of the model so they introduce energy
functions here and they say okay we can
have a policy on X so if we're given a
concept W and if we're given an A we can
have a policy over X which basically
means we can find X's that are
compatible with that by running gradient
descent here you see there is an XK
minus 1 and we are running gradient
descent on the energy function
with respect to X to find a better X
that satisfies the energy function given
those inputs and the same if we want to
find an attention mask we are running
gradient descent on the attention mask
again in order to satisfy the same
energy function so you see the inputs
are both times the same the concept here
we can input square here we can input
square but the difference is what we're
running gradient descent on and what we
keep constant and I would get I would
add a third line here actually because
we can also if we're given an X and an A
we can also infer a W and that's going
to be an integral part so if I have this
right here and this situation and I have
say I have a tension on these for now I
can ask the model so I'm given X and I'm
given a I can ask the model to infer W
and the model should ideally output ha
this is square now the model isn't going
to output square the model is going to
output a vector representation of square
right so the model is going to output
square but as a vector of numbers
because that's how we've trained it W
isn't it is the embedding but what we
can then do later is we can say okay I'm
not going to tell you it's a square you
just come up with a vector W it
describes this situation and now I'm
going to take that vector W that you
came up with miss mister or missus model
and I'm going to take tell you a new
situation this situation right here and
I'm going to now give you X and I'm
going to give you the W that you
yourself have output and now please
tell me what's the a and then the model
is of course supposed to tell you oh
these four
here or the a so without without ever
telling that it should be a square what
you can do is you can let the model
infer a W from one example situation and
then transfer that W to a new situation
so it can identify you can just say
whatever concept I have up here please
apply that same concept which is the W
down here and this is the entire paper
now this is the concept learning through
energy based models okay so that is kind
of a third line I would add down here
you can infer a concept vector if you're
given the X and the a so in order to do
all this their energy function is going
to be a so called relational neural
network so what you'll have is you'll
have a simple neural network a
multi-layer perceptron that always
connects two entities to each other with
the concept vector and then this is a
belief a sigmoid that connects the
attention masks of the two and then you
simply sum over all pairs of two entries
in your model and then you send that
through an MLP sorry through an MLP
again this I believe is not so important
it's just important that they can feed
this entire situation the X the a and
the W they can basically feed into a
neural network in the neural network
comes up with a number of how well those
three things fit together and then you
can transfer these concepts that's
pretty cool now the only question is of
course and we've always said we're given
an energy function or just we just have
it but of course this is a neural
network and the neural network has
parameters and the parameters we don't
know what good parameters are at the
beginning so we need to train this thing
and again the reason why these are toy
problems right here is I mean we'll get
to why it's computational but this is
kind of a new field
I believe in machine learning at least I
come from classical machine learning and
we only ever
have used like SGD to train and we only
have her have produced models that one
shot produce something and here
we this is a I believe there's a new
concept where you use gradient descent
as part of the output and that makes a
lot of trouble and so that's why we work
in toy problems so what this this here
is the situation I described you have a
demo event where you're given the X and
the a and you're supposed to infer the W
so the question here is what's the W and
the model will come up with a W and
you're not gonna do anything you're not
right now you're simply gonna take that
W and tell it oh well here is a so
called
test event so please apply the W you
came up with in this test event and
please find me the the a in this case
that satisfies the W and the X I give
you here and of course the a right here
is as you can see even you don't know
that it's a square and the actual
concept here is move the grey ball to
the middle of the square right that that
is it here but no one has told me this I
just looked at the picture so the the
correct answer here would be to place
attention on those four things and then
to take this thing and move it to the
middle right here in in the in this over
here so that would be the correct answer
now the question is how do you train
something like this and they they show
that they so this is the loss function
right here the loss function is they
give you a concept and an initial
situation and you're supposed to infer
the x1 and the a and the loss function
is simply the negative log likelihood of
that but what does that mean
so will will make it easier if if you
have this this procedure right here
where you have
demo event this up here this is demo and
this is a test event how are you going
this entire procedure how are you going
to learn the energy function well in
this case this entire procedure this
entire thing is one training sample
sample but usually we have input and
label and now here it's much more
complicated because so we have input
okay that's this X and this a cool but
then we have SGD as integral part of the
procedure to determine the W and now
what we could do is just apply a loss to
the W but we don't because we don't know
what the embedding space for the
concepts is we could maybe train a
classifier but in this case we want to
train the ability to transfer these
concepts so our training sample needs to
be one time transferring a concept so
SGD for one is part of our process here
and not only that but then this this X
here of course is also part of our
training sample write this up here as X
0 and this here is X 1 and now we need
to find this a this attention mask and
that is an SGD again remember inferring
anything through the energy function is
a gradient descent process so ultimately
our one training example consists of X 0
a at the beginning so let's call that a
zero it consists of the SGD procedure to
find W it consists of X 1 and they
consist of the SGD procedure to find a
the a 1 the output a and then that will
give us the output a the a 1 so this
here is our input in the classical
machine and this would be our X and this
here would be our label Y and that's
what we trained on we trained so it such
that the output right here
the
this is of course sorry this is of
course the Y hat this is what we predict
and in the training sample we just write
a little generator that will you know
make this situation that knows what the
concept is right it will say okay I'm
gonna make an example for a square then
it make this will make the attention
mask for a square and then it will make
the new situation again with a square
but not tell us the attention mask there
and it will make the attention mask into
the true Y so at the end we can compare
what our model output the attention mask
we output here without ever knowing that
it should be a square and we have the
true label which comes out of the
generator that at the beginning decided
that it should be a square and then the
loss in the distance between those two
that's our loss this is an in this is an
enormous procedure to get a loss and
most crucially you have to back
propagate through optimization
procedures and this is something that we
just can't do yet in our models if you
take an image a resonate 50 right right
now we do one forward propagation to get
a label in this procedure if you had two
back propagate through the optimization
procedure for each sample you would need
to basically back propagate through 50
forward passes of the resonate if you if
your optimization procedure is 50 steps
long and that is just not feasible right
now so that's why we don't do it but I
believe maybe once we find a smart way
of back propping through optimization
procedures a whole lot of these things
will become the new and new wave and
machine learning I really I'm excited -
I'm pretty sure it doesn't work yet and
this is very figley fiddly work but I'm
excited by the prospect that we can do
this so this is the training procedure
right
you've given X
0 x1 and a and you Optima is in order to
infer the concept behind it right the
generator that your level generator of
your training data it knows the concept
it has a concept in mind when it
generated this but you're not telling
your model what the concept is it needs
to infer that and then using the model
thing that the model inferred you can
either give it x0 and x1 and infer a or
you can give it the X and the a and in
forex you can do either of those right
these are called identification or
generation respectively and then you
compare the output here to what the
generator at the beginning thought again
it's not telling you it's that's because
that's the label and you compare this to
that and that will be your loss to train
your energy function parameters so your
training samples if you think of this
entire thing as one forward pass of the
model then it's just classic machine
learning right you have a training
sample which is one forward pass and you
have a corresponding label that you
infirm so let's jump to the experiments
right here experiments are actually
pretty cool so what they've done is for
example have taken the concept of being
far apart from something now being far
apart so that the little X needs to be
as far away as possible from the ball
that has the attention on it so if you
do generation and you start the little X
right here and you ask the model where
please infer the next state of the world
it will push that little X away right
here and in color you can see the energy
function valleys of the position of the
X so it pushes it away from this thing
but if you take the same concept
embedding the concept embedding of being
far away but you don't do generation you
do identification which means you infer
the a then it will simply tell you that
this ball right here is the furthest
away from the X right so you can do all
sorts of things like this and
transferring concepts I find this here
pretty interesting so they had to have
two different concepts one concept is
read as an identification you need to
identify the red ball but the other
concept is you need to turn something
red right you need to take a ball that
is maybe now blue and of course the
color you can gradient descent on the
colors you'd need to make it red and
since the energy function
it just takes three input X a and W it
doesn't you you you're not going to tell
it right now in which situation you are
it has to create create this W embedding
space through learning and if you do it
with those two concepts then it will put
the make something red concept and the
is something red concepts in the same
places so this is a PCA and then blue I
think these blue is the attention codes
for identify the red things and in red
or the generation code for make
something red and they will be put in
the same place which is pretty cool it
means that the energy function really
learns the feature of something being
red
I find this pretty pretty neat and then
here they they have some experiments
where they basically show we need that
gradient descent optimization procedure
because only after many steps will will
the energy function basically be aligned
with the concept that you want so if you
have a zero shot model like just one
forward pass as we do here you'll see
that the energy function that is
supposed to make a circle from samples
right this is the example concept right
here it if you just have a one shot
model it will it cannot but in this case
at least it doesn't learn to one shot
produce only if you opt in
for a few steps will it get this so you
optimize at inference time and that
seems to be very important you can see
again here demonstrations of this so the
example is this and then the model as
you can see after 20 steps learn
optimizes the points to go to these
locations whereas after only one step it
didn't do that yet so there are complex
things at work here and this column here
is where you don't have a relational or
neural network so you can't basically
capture dependencies between things so
you you have no chance of making a
square because you don't know where the
things are in relation to each other but
that's more of an engineering question
their point is basically that if you
have models that do an optimization at
inference time they are much more
powerful than models that just do a
one-shot forward pass it's sort of like
an auto regressive model in NLP versus a
non auto regressive model that produces
all words at once if you produce all
words of a sentence at once no word can
depend on any other word and you can
just come loose
independent or you can just produce
independent things which will make the
sentence often not make any sense
they also have this KL objective which
is a regularizer
which I believe that's just a trial and
error they built it in because but it is
a regularizer
I don't want to really go into that and
then they they do demonstration in and
they re-enacted on a robot the
demonstration here is that there is a
situation where two things have a
tension on and you're supposed to move
something into the middle of the two
things so that's the content you don't
tell the robot the concept it needs to
learn that from data and then infer that
this is the concept that you want and
then transfer that to the other
environment now you know this you look
you know there's this robot environment
but ultimately they still encode the
positions of these things and the
position of that and really all you have
to do
different here is that instead of moving
this actuator directly you need to like
calculate what you need to do to the
individual joints in the robot so I
think this is maybe because it's open AI
and it needs to you know look robot II
and stuff but the problem here is not
really different it's it's not even it's
not real-world
transfer or anything so yeah let's let
go through some of the things they can
learn with this so you can see here they
can learn these regional geometric
shapes and so on the left is the example
event that the model needs to take the
concept from now this is this is I
believe very much identification so what
they did is they trained with a data set
where all of these appear right so this
there are squares there are lines there
are circles so this is maybe my
criticism here that it is not so much to
generally infer a concept it is more
like identify the concept so the model
basically just needs to decide is this
line is the circle or is this square
because that was those things were in
the training data set it would be nice
to see how this generalizes to general
concepts or if we can even make that if
we can have a zero shot concept
inference and then transfer those
concepts to other things maybe that's
already happening
I don't I don't know so here the spatial
arrangement is to either be close to
something or to be between two things so
if the attention is on two things you
want in between so you see the top ones
are the demonstrations it needs to
recognize the concept and it needs to
basically optimize to fulfill that
concept shapes so to make shapes is mmm
oh yeah there's a triangle right again
this this this just very much I believe
relies on recognition and not actual
understanding of what a triangle
here you have proximity being closer
being far apart what else is cool oh
yeah if the recognition for the same
task right you need to identify the ball
that is closer for and here you really
also see the optimization procedure in
action where for example at the
beginning of each flicker you kind of
see the attention being everywhere and
then stabilizing to one or two points so
if two points are equally close or far
apart you'll see the attention being on
multiple points which is pretty cool
right so that means the model really
learns this this is concept here's the
count quantity so you can either have
one two or larger than three or
something yeah that seems like they
tried three and four and didn't work so
they just said I will just do larger
than three and here is this robot thing
where it also always needs to move in
between now this this is the part that
I'm not really impressed with but you
know whatever whatever you want okay I
hope this was a good introduction to
energy functions what you can do with
them what I think of them end of this
paper it is a pretty cool paper it yes
it only works on toy problems so far but
I believe this is one interesting
direction of future machine learning and
something yet to be very much explored
if you like this content please
subscribe tell all of your friends about
it share and I'll see you next time bye
bye